alors on va regarder un petit peu les
fleurs puisque les fleurs sont
maintenant il suffit souvent de se
baisser pour les voir ou alors de
regarder dans l'arbre et on voit
l'apparition des fleurs mâles et des
fleurs femelles en haut en bas il faut
regarder partout 117 hectares de trésor
à découvrir pendant 2h la forêt
domaniale de Maurepas dévoile ses
secrets à cette vingtaine de randonneurs
une balade organisée par l'Office
national des forêts à l'occasion des
Estivales c'est un moyen un moment de
rencontre avec les usagers de la forêt
et un forestier qui explique que la
faune la flore la gestion et comment
pousse une forêt et toutes les actions
qui sont menées dans cette forêt et ça
permet de pouvoir reprendre un dialogue
et expliquer les trois missions de
l'Office sociale des forêts la première
mission la production de bois la
deuxième mission la protection des
espèces et la troisième mission à
l'accueil du public la longueur des
aiguilles pour déterminer un résineux
est très important le nombre d'aiguilles
qui sont attachés sur l'axe cent de la
tige est importante chaîne châtaignier
pin sylvestre ou encore où le jeu est de
les reconnaître ou du moins d'apprendre
à les différencier pas d’interrogation
surprise mais des petits conseils pour
mieux profiter de sa balade toutes les
essences et puis là on fait peu de
chemin et en découvre beaucoup de choses
voilà donc tout ça c'est très
intéressant c'est très intéressant oui
parce que souvent les gens s'interrogent
le fait pour pourquoi les l'ONF laisse
des arbres mourir et les coupent pas
donc voilà donc il nous a bien expliqué
pourquoi donc c'est voilà ça nous
apprend beaucoup sur la nature sur la
biodiversité sur les sur les arbres sur
nos forêts en général donc c'est un
signe aussi pour nous donc de d'être
sensibilisé parce qu'on en dépend la
nature en envie sans nature il y a pas
de il y a pas de vie prochain
rendez-vous forestier avec l'OMF le
mercredi 26 juillet dans la forêt
domaniale de Fausses Reposes à noter
aussi dans vos agendas tous en forêt le
27 septembre prochain cette site
yvelinois seront mis à l'honneur
[Musique]